[Applaudissements]
m
pis elle même y voir
est ce que de toute la france est chaud
parisien nous
[Applaudissements]
les peintures et pâteux sourit serre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on en compte de cette rivière qui
ferment des
visiteurs
elle
rappelle que celle qui vient tout faire
- 12 inoa python hell maetel nos
déchets qui viennent qu'ils ferment nos
usines en dépit des hausses étaient
et alors
[Musique]
mes camarades chers collègues cerné lui
on va patienter un petit peu ici parce
que ça ça arrive encore on est bien trop
nombreux donc le tampon structure
cortège on va rester un peu ici qui pour
signifier le révérend on vient pas pour
rien on veut là les fermetures de lits
vont les créations peste les spéciales
et les belges des personnels nécessaires
au fonctionnement de nos capitaux
publics
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
bonsoir
j'ai fait pas on
du marathon vert
ouais ouais
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est là on est
or même si vraiment pas nouveau mais là
c'est pour l'hôpital public le stade est
la ré publique belge hiver on ne veut
pas du monde et là on est là
au mélo
même s'ils veulent pas nous donner la
c'est pour le put être publique laisse
tomber la république même si vert on ne
veut pas de mandela
au delà
o o
bien sûr de nous mais là
c'est pour les fidèles public
resteraient république bams hiver on ne
veut pas nous rendre là
[Musique]
olé
au jeu suivant mais pas nous
c'est pour l'hôpital public restaurer la
république même si l'euro ne veut pas
nous vendent et là
hall est là
même si bon on ne m'a pas nommé là
c'est pour l'hôpital public
l'hostellerie fini même si vert en eux
mais par nous on est là
[Applaudissements]
le stade olympique
on
même si le rendement nous sommes là
c'est pour leur fidèle public
l'ostendais la république même si mr ans
ne veut pas nous bord de la
route
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
même si bordeaux
c'est par le publics laissent
tomber leur public koxie vers le bas du
monde la
connaît
merci je m'en vais pas nommer
[Musique]
c'est pour le fidèle public l'hosto des
la république même si vers mes copains
du monde est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
et
hier
regard du vivant
[Musique]
bah
bertal
[Musique]
alors
pour
[Applaudissements]
qui
à
[Musique]
on va avancer en direction du ministère
le cortège est bien structuré êtes
chauds pour l'hôpital pour défendre le
profi ter étaient mêlés aux
fonctionnaires
aux réponses tepes réputé public erp est
épaisse pour l'hôpital public des postes
d brest pour les vidal public des postes
des postes pour le pit à l'oubli des
boss des bosses pour le middle pluie
n'est pas
[Musique]
du fait aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour l'habitat du big boss des bosses
pour la publics la poste la poste
pour leur pique nique
l'épreuve pour leur des nanars
eux veulent lâche et criminel qui fait
le bras fusil noah pub est mince entre
elles nanard elle vole à celles
qui ferment d'un juno happy town has
auxquels nos marais
qui ferment les usines sont peter kay
hian r'n'b
qui fait menez usines et habiter nos
écoles denner élevé décès qui ignorent
qu'ils ferment nos usines nos hôpitaux
et les écoles y en a elles deux ces
criminels qu'ils ferment nos usines nos
hôpitaux et nos écoles nos nerfs
belle de ces guignols qui ferment dans
l'usiné capitaine becker
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prospeed alliés fatigué mais toujours
terre ou hospitaliers fatigué mais
toujours
espitalier fatigué mais toujours
hospitalier fatigué mais tu es lourds et
bus hospitalier fatigués mais toujours
hospitalier est fatigué mais toujours
hospitalier fatigué mais toujours
et ce but qu'elle est fatiguée mais
toujours baby
[Musique]
la ras-le-bol des skieurs qui forment en
sus une offre people of écoles y en a
ras belle vaisselle signalent qu'ils
ferment nos usines nos hôpitaux nos
écoles y en a ras le bol de ces guignols
qui ferment nos usines nos hôpitaux nos
écoles nos marc albert
17/1 qu'ils ferment nos usines aux
hôpitaux écoles y en a
deux c'est
qu'ils ferment les usines à se piquer
mais c'est un
décès
qui ferment du gym hôpitaux et des mains
pour celles
qui ferment nos usines nos hôpitaux nos
écoles ionia
décès
qui diffèrent ou deux usines oiseaux
piquer votre ego lyonnais révèle que
celles qui violent qui fait mal aux
usines européennes aux écoles leur
ras-le-bol de cette ligne qui ferment
des usines est un
c'est elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
moyen
oui
[Musique]
et
il
à
il est
et voilà
habiter m
[Musique]
m
le
bo
si tu savais
[Musique]
c'est
oui mais non
vidéo oui
on trouve que dieu un officiel sans
commencer le procès des emplois dans
tout le temps là ce sens unique
[Musique]
il
marie
[Musique]
non
alors
[Musique]
g
mais pardon
[Musique]
on
comment
[Musique]
tout ça
c'est
là
[Musique]
et
voilà
à l'école
[Musique]
m
hélas
je
[Musique]
non
puis la famille
[Musique]
oui
m
voilà
ouais
dans
[Musique]
et pendant que
il
voilà
[Musique]
plus
2 bombay
[Musique]
quoi
m
[Musique]
non
attendez
voilà
[Musique]
depuis août
non 1
[Musique]
il
je
en
à
famille
donc on
[Musique]
com
parce que c'est ça notre sens de ce
n'est pas très nombreux mais trop savoir
que derrière nos cantons et aujourd'hui
vous avez des patients qui attendent
dans les services des urgences vous avez
tous de 90 en réanimation soins
intensifs vous avez tout fait tous deux
qui sont pour en province et kwamashu
avoir un accès au point où vous avez des
territoires de santé ou bien plus
d'ostheim heures plus tard dialogue où
j'ai plus de psychiatres et fait tout ça
qu'il faut voir et ça c'est celle qui
porte notre démarche aujourd'hui merci
[Musique]
au fait merci à patrick
touchons ici
dp reconnaît depuis le gentil cayenne
fuyez
[Musique]
bresson l'été 2011
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pour les gagner
je sais que
tout près des
berges de
l'adour
de tout
obama se serait
passé de sous traitance ils sont payés
c'est un peu tout cas très
tard c'est que service rendez vous très
chers bonne qualité de merde
j'ai donné à
adjamé
démons présente le collectif interdite
elle est médecin à l'hôpital bichat
oui bonjour à tous merci est possible on
est tous là pour les plus pauvres tel
public l'excellent soir et qu'ils ont
miné les faits mais le danger
on est là tous ensemble
pour des maisons fleuries ils ont réussi
ajoie les effectifs et gérons pas à ce
que les classiques et le désir des soins
uniques et les rations d'effectifs
ça devrait inclure gamme un sur cinq
comme en suisse comment gallito rouge un
calme en option vous europe 1 sur 14 ha
sur 15 et le gouvernement s'étonne que
les infirmières s'enfuit de montcalm 30%
des postes de praticiens pour gagner ne
sont pas tenues on n'entend pas mais
devant l'espagne en dé soigner adoration
pour nos courses par les conçoit les
territoires seront
exécutés d'ici les groupes sans accès
presque 100 jours sans médecin portait
cette aura duré
touchons
[Musique]
et
bourdeau
[Musique]
super
m
[Musique]
depuis
m
[Musique]
d
mathieu
là
10e
venir
/
la monnaie
non
[Musique]
et
pour le côté
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
moi je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh oui
[Applaudissements]
les ignorer
m
[Musique]
le jeu peut
titulaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh mais la
mairie
m
andrew pitt elle publie ce soit lui même
si ça ne veut pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on n'est pas ce que l'on crut délit t
as pour l'hôpital public on veut des
lits des passes pour l'hôpital public
[Musique]
je pars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
on peut faire je suis toi
public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
et
parce que rires
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les filets
ouais
c'est tout
et
[Musique]
shi
toujours votre forme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pour moi
les sarthois
[Musique]
dédié au jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on irait vers ans et n'avait n'avait
l'oci
rendez vous
[Musique]
il faut se laver
voilà
m
[Musique]
pourquoi
elle
[Applaudissements]
colère
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
les gars
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les destins
[Musique]
étude
parue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
la vie
et
oui
[Musique]
mais bon
pas le voilà on
[Musique]
m
avg
[Applaudissements]
les idées
notre ami
[Musique]
même si
via
[Musique]
on est là on y est
même si berne ne veut pas tout on est là
pour notre hôpital public les stocks de
la république même si berne ne met pas
nous on est là
[Musique]
les
thèmes suivants nous voler la faune
famille sa clinique sauf que dans les
faits super on ne va pas vous mentir
[Musique]
on est dans
le sud est vrai
qu'on est très sain qui vit presque de
la république comme si l'iran ne veut
pas donner
à
on
ne se met pas tout
on le connaît la nuit que le côté même
si mr en eux
[Musique]
au
contre
[Musique]
prendre part
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
hôpital est pas toujours
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est récurrente dans
l'histoire parce que ça soit ianaïev que
ça sert à tout les transports
si
chaque beaujon 1 on nous parle de crise
sanitaire mais ça les gêne pas de
charmer destruction des vidéos puissante
chez et nous nous refusons ça je sais
plus qu'alain de spiegeleer et la
population vous êtes rendus dans les
airs vous vous faisiez
mauricie devoir de voter avec leur
complicité est le directeur des réponses
on me va nous donner de réponse mais la
réponse une attelle qui continue à
former des pluies continues avant
d'efforts mais continue à rendre des
effectifs nous à cette contrainte
éducation me laisse quelquefois la
destruction programmée de rita clubic et
c'est pour ça qu'on est là aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le même amour
que non
jack l'hôpital makati jacquot jour match
est plié de plus thomas
kg du baudet
[Musique]
m
mais pas répondre aux revendications
légitimes 1 allez voir un médiateur en
besoin médiateur vous avez un médiateur
quelle ordure médiator
[Musique]
comme zemmour c'est
l'indication de toute sa population
éducation des hospitaliers boselli
[Musique]
et si des relevés comprend on s'aidera
rendez vous chez makro
parce que lui répondant mois occident le
groupe est très bon
d
[Musique]
ben
ali
[Applaudissements]
fait troublant
[Musique]
conditionnée aqua
je tiens
[Musique]
mais moi ça qu'on est là gens qui
passent nombreux amis et proches pour
leur survie
[Musique]
gaudy
ces deux pointures du malaise à paris
avec horaires de fermeture de lier deux
des trois quilles au maillet paris
et de jets à pleurtuit domaine la
famille
des fermetures de lits
au contraire
[Musique]
psychanalyste est las de mai est
toujours
compliqué
[Musique]
tant qu elle
devenait je crois de camara du tout
français
[Applaudissements]
on survivre en ont-ils indécent de
l'essor on va désormais rencontrer pour
répondre et d'éducation on est très mal
on exactement
en tout cas nous on est là on après ce
déplacement et on va lui démontrer on
est prêt à tout pour faire aboutir les
revendications
[Applaudissements]
on
même si jérôme
[Musique]
m
oh
[Applaudissements]
hélas
[Musique]
m
à
on
[Musique]
contrôler
peter publics notamment mais
on a gagné
[Musique]
là
trente piteuses public lost hobo la
république même si elle ne veut pas de
nous on est là
qu on en aurait défense des hôpitaux on
est là pour la défense de nos hôpitaux
publics et quand c'est non c'est non et
quand c'est nous et quand ces mots
pour dire revendications monsieur veut
et qu'on m'a dit la tomate séchée me
conduirait si on n'est pas satisfait
des lits et pest pour les public
kerry des postes pour le pilote du bit
[Musique]
là
pour la saint jean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sais pas où l'hôpital public me gally
débat pour l'hôpital public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non pas
abonnés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
oh
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
la période épatant
c'est
m
[Musique]
en veux pas
on venait d'un père y est
[Musique]
ça qu on vient chez toi
ô
[Musique]
il est
vrai qu on n'aurait pas
on veut les
statutaires et celle pour s'accrocher
quoi
[Musique]
les travaux
on les
attend
je sais
[Musique]
merci
m
[Musique]
heureux
et
mon
coeur
m
moi de mon corps
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand c'est non c'est non
c'est non c'est non jeûneurs
16 h et des fermetures de lits
français les fermetures de lits
[Applaudissements]
refaire un maximum d'ennemis on a sauvé
mon côté bien et très impressionnant du
tertiaire fois les camarades de la hyène
qui sont là qui sont que j'ai pris avec
des délégations loire atlantique et
négation du maine-et-loire de demander
d'où on y de porc tout en france et tous
les syndicats du de france et des cinq
provinces qui sont souvent
parvenir à me suggérer que ces
fermetures
or les créations de postes statutaires
on veut des infirmières j'aurais aussi
des moyens pour l'essai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
à
même si belle
pour notre hôpital public losc n'est pas
la république
mais on ne peut pas nous on est né
merci mais en attendant nous sommes
hélas
à pour notre hôpital public l'ostendais
la république même si berne ne veut pas
dire
même si berne n'a même pas nouveau mais
là
pour notre hôpital public lawson l'arep
univers
on
le cyber on ne peut pas nous mais là où
notre hôpital public l'hosto des la
république même si les vents ne
devraient pas on va gagner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour notre fidèle public l'ostendais la
république bensi verts en avaient pas
nous rendait là et on sera là on sera
même si vert on ne va pas là nous on
sera là pour notre hôpital public
l'hosto de la république même si vert on
ne veut pas de broussailles
[Musique]
même si beyrouth n'a pas nommé là
pour notre hôpital public l'hosto de la
république même si vert en inde par nous
on est là
[Musique]
m
les hospitaliers est ce que vous êtes là
juste un check up ou parce que vous êtes
là
on est comme en mille histoires parce
qu'on veut donner des postes
[Musique]
pour le corps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un délit
[Applaudissements]
allez messieurs les ministres vers
metz hospitalier de jet à pertuis de
malades à paris ceux-là vais vous dire
arrêt à des fermetures de lits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
température paris
k
et allez à un
délit
[Applaudissements]
à
monsieur véran vous devez un temps des
revendications comme jeudi de dieppe à
pertuis de maillane à paris tous ont été
voir leur patron des jeunes teva les
directeurs des hôpitaux on ne répète pas
les hôtes et vend les ars on ne nous
répond toujours pas sorti ou plus être
ministre vous êtes à tutelle vous ne
verrez pas les revendications à un arrêt
à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais des fermetures de lits
cameron jusqu'ici on va s'avancer un
petit peu parce qu'on a beaucoup de
monde derrière ça un train de bloquer
camarades de devoirs à sarzeau et ceux
qui sont derrière n'hésitez pas à
déborder parce que de toute façon parler
nulle part ailleurs il ya des barrières
donc n'hésitez pas à vous rapprocher
vous débordez sur les sur les côtés pour
laisser que les camarades qui sont
derrière puissent s'approcher le plus
possible avec nous et puisse reprendre
tout slogan tous en coeur merci à vous
rendez vous
pour l'attack ou du
délit d'achat pour la famille
on veut gagner
[Musique]
on veut des riches dépensent boulot
c'est a subie
aux mains d'élus dépenses pour leur
talent public
on peut d y faire face pour l'hôpital
public
roman d'alice dépasse pour le public
[Applaudissements]
avant delhi dépenses pour la sphère
publique
aux délits dépenses pour l'achat public
[Musique]
m
eni
pour l'heure que chaque public
on veut des lits des princes pour le
public
en qualité passe alors
[Musique]
au journaliste est pas d'un coup
à
on verra
[Musique]
moi
un bond à lui d'abord pour la technique
[Musique]
on venait lui des postes pour la dette
publique
[Musique]
ont beau d'elie baup
et puis vous suivront même si ça vous
fait pas état on est là on est là même
si l'euro ne devait pas où on est a
pour notre hôpital public le sto de la
république même si véro ne veut pas loin
de là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
on est là on est là
même si véro ne veut pas nous on est là
pour notre hôpital public costaud de la
république même si berne ne veut pas
nous on est là
à
[Musique]
alors
on est là on est là
à même si véro n'avait pas nous on est
là
à contrôler vital public le sceau de la
république même si berne ne veut pas
dire on est là
il
[Musique]
on est là on est là même si vers andré
va nous on est là
ah bon notre hôpital public le sceau de
la république même sidérant ne veux pas
qu'on en est là
en europe une amie
je crois
[Musique]
je ne peux pas vous
la supplie de l'ordre
c'est vraiment
oh
il
[Musique]
et on est à des tiers pour faire tuer de
manière à paris fournier arrêt arrêt de
fermetures de lits
[Applaudissements]
arrêt des cars de thurgovie
[Musique]
fermeture grille
[Applaudissements]
arrêt des fermetures de lits
diop a parti le bal à paris arrêt aurait
la fermeture quasi arrêt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi je vais rectifier quelque
chose parce que le cadrage de bacalan
c'est exprès en france est perdu
excusez-moi kamar est de prendre un peu
côte d'azur qui est là avec nous
aujourd'hui et les hôpitaux de jets sont
là aujourd'hui aussi avec nous bayer
mais laissez le mot rigueur dans la voix
m
j'avais eu raison d'aller au bout la
suite d'un capot lève mon verre et des
sous pression avec des fermetures de
lits de verhoeven entendre aujourd'hui
parce que y'en a marre on nous a collé
la crise sanitaire il reste quand même
délicat des hôpitaux est un méchant et
beaujon à paris 400 miroir des
structures hospitalières brement surtout
les maisons postale que maison ce
critère ce soit aux hôpitaux tente de
remettre à des murs l'augmentation des
salaires pour nos soldats parce que je
lance pierres aux voeux des postes tels
ou au maintien de toutes les structures
hospitalières en ligne la page
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on veut d'abord pour las vegas baby
l'idée pour l'hôpital public
organisé porte pour l'habitacle libye
[Musique]
à
voilà
on guérit n'est pas pour la premi
on veut gagner pas pour l'hôpital public
on vous l udaf un mot l'hôpital
[Musique]
et
magali écosse
[Musique]
les autres
allez excusez moi la revalorisation
c'est pour le personnel mais détient
médicaux ces squales et non soignant les
avis atypique centaines de mousse
pratiques ne sont pas retournés
l'hôpital public on ne peut pas
fonctionner c'est pour tout le monde des
revalorisations
et puis moi je vois c'est la sécu si
mobilise le guide le site vous pouvez me
sentais aussi ça serait bien et si leurs
cotisations sociales pouvaient financer
l'hôpital ça serait très bien
augmentation du service public et privé
olivier véran
ministre à tolérant des fermetures on
n'en veut pas on veut des interviews des
postes statutaires
et je sais plus courants mais là je
plaisante on essaie de discuter moi
d'habitude c'est l'achète
eh oui
[Musique]
non en suspension non l obligation
l'hôpital italien souffrance toc
réintégration de tous les suspenses on
ne mange ya ses portes tout le monde non
pas sa leader curé aussi mais bon
olivier bérard
midi strates et les rangs
des fermetures on n'en veut pas on veut
des infirmières des postes statutaires
et c'est pour ça qu'on vient chez toi
[Musique]
vous
oui
[Musique]
alors je pense que pu taxer les sachets
légitime qu'un camarade hospitalier
viennent s'exprimer il ya là plusieurs
de calan est je vous demanderais
d'écouté de se voir reprocher des gamins
de spider hier au tac à venir pour
parler un petit peu d'incitations
pourquoi ils sont là aujourd'hui
et pourquoi nous sommes avec eux
aujourd'hui
on commence à être commencer par les
hôpitaux
de pays talhouarn
baleine
lavage donc je te laisse sa parole
bonjour camarades
alors je suis le secrétaire syndical
pour sourire du centre hospitalier de
laval même si l'accès m'a pas trop avec
pinault comme tous les hôpitaux en
soutien notre moyenne et notre hôpital
du nord-mayenne c'est vrai que sa part
de la mayenne partout où il ya des
difficultés à commencer par les urgences
dans la gériatrie par les ehpad la
dernière main notre directeur nous
interdit de retourner dans les services
parce que la cohydro prince dom est sûre
en irak chsct on n'acceptera pas
quand on dénonce dans les journaux tout
ce qui se passe on nous engueule ans
étaient eux en disant qu'on fait de la
diffamation ou à ce qui se passe au
centre hospitalier de vannes
douce
nous on est là pour soutenir
tous les hôpitaux on n'est pas resté de
un autre hôpital comme demander
certaines syndicats on est tous monter
ici parce que c'est ici que ça se décide
devant le ministère
hier
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues chers camarades bonjour
à tous je vous apporte le salut des
syndicats force ouvrière des régions
pays de la loire
[Musique]
nos collègues et nos camarades de
mayenne avec l'association audace était
plus de 4000 en octobre dernier pour une
seconde manifestation parce que la rs
finalement le bras armé du ministre
véran veut leur imposer la fermeture des
services de chirurgie des soins continus
la population les personnels refusent
exigent le maintien de tous les lits les
recrutements nécessaires parce
qu'aujourd'hui la seule réponse du
ministère si vous dire tu les payes
soignants dans les placards est pe et pv
effet ce gouvernement qui a fait fermer
ses 5700 lit en pleine crise épidémique
qui l'a suspendu qu'est-ce qu'il soit
non les hôpitaux ses célèbres des contre
l'épidémie mais canal et mes collègues
on ne pouvait accepter les 4000
manifestants à mayenne ont les mêmes
revendications qu'elle est muni que nous
sommes aujourd'hui et que les centaines
de milliers que tous aient mené les
établissements santé publics et privés
nous refusons nous refusons cette
politique qui vise à détruire le les
lits d'hospitalisation réduire la masse
salariale
titularise les 200000 les 200000
contractuels de la fonction publique
hospitalière qu'ils augmentent les
places dans les facs de médecine tous
les autres montrent les places dans les
ifsi et après le cadre on nous donnait
des muets ils viendront s'exprimer
devant nous aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
cas et nous sommes ici pour exiger leur
est pure et simple immédiate de toutes
les fermetures de lits de toutes les
restructurations
allez y mais gare des groupes de
discussion nous n'en voulons pas nous
non plus maintenant si dc des réponses
que nous exigeons les délégations vont
être reçus sous reçu en ce moment et si
le ministre si ce gouvernement ne répond
pas par l'arrêt immédiat de tout ça et
bien nous nous adresserons à matheron
directement parce qu'ils sont
responsables mais km ont laissé leur vie
l'indication vivement people public
alors je le tape à l'ats géraldine de
l'hôpital du vinatier
[Applaudissements]
qaraqe bonjour je vous apporte le salut
de nos camarades de l'hôpital
psychiatrique du vinatier dans leurs
oeufs nous sommes montés un ici à paris
suite à l'appel de mayenne parce que
nous avons les mêmes revendications pour
un syndicat et fo et cgt du vinatier et
une cinquantaine de lyon
alors je suis d'accord avec ce que
camatte open juste avant lundi sur le
vinatier toutes les décisions et toutes
les mesures de la direction sont des
attaques directes contre les laisse les
soignants contre les personnels et au
final contre les passions nous avons
multiplié les délégations les rencontres
entre la direction et la direction
n'apporte jamais aucune réponse c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui nous sommes ici
devant le ministère là où est là où les
décisions se prennent et c zéro et
macron les responsables de la situation
de l'hôpital aujourd'hui il monte des
soignants dans les hôpitaux il ya vingt
mille collègues qui sont suspendus
commencé par intégrer est suspendu
aujourd'hui sur le bim et ils ont fermé
150 filiales il enferme dans aujourd'hui
sans le gouvernement où il fait un délit
tous les jours tous les jours ils
suppriment des postes et ferme des lits
aujourd'hui ouvrant des comptes et nous
sommes ici pour un vent la satisfaction
de toutes nos revendications
plus aucune fermeture des lits en poche
de personnel réintégration des suspendus
l'otage est capable de ta panier du chu
de grenoble
bonjour à tous de la part de tous les
soignants nous nous sommes impliqués
depuis plus de 10 ans dans des démarches
qualité d'amélioration des soins
constants malgré la diminution des
moyens face à la situation nous avons
besoin de toutes les forces vives de
tous les soignants suspendu de tous ceux
qui connaissent leur métier et qui sont
au chaud les du patient pour faire face
à tout ça et continuer la lutte pour
améliorer les soins dans la situation où
on est
quelle qualité des soins
à quelques élites face à quelle qualité
des soins on est actuellement en
soignant sur le terrain avec les blocs
qui fait les interventions qui se décale
des services d'urgence qui ferment on a
besoin de toutes les forces on a besoin
d écouter alors que la chasse se met en
route pour faire l'accréditation qualité
des établissements de santé en 2022
comment voulez vous que les soignants
continue à s'impliquer dans ses
démarches alors qu'ils ont besoin d'être
absolument sûr le terrain à la fois pour
la recherche médicale contre le convive
mais aussi pour tous les autres patients
atteints de maladies chroniques pour
poursuivre leur prise en charge parce qu
ils sont les oubliés dans la crise
certains n'ont plus accès à l'hôpital il
ya des retards diagnostic et ça ça n'est
pas possible en france en 2021 merci à
tous et evennou et écoutez nous
hockey canada drones et celles de la
région paca
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je rectifie maintenance et la
région paca parce qu'ils ont retiré la
région corse l'écouté je représente ici
je ce quota du syndicat fo des
hospitalier d'aix pertuis mais le plus
important c'est que lors de l'assemblée
générale du personnel tu mènes 3
novembre en présence des deux syndicats
les trois autres syndicats cgt et cfdt
j'ai le mandat pour représenter le
personnel par vote et les syndicats fo
cgt cfdt sur les mêmes revendications
que nous avons tous et toutes sur aix en
provence c'est pas très compliqué c'est
pareil que chez vous en juillet août il
ya eu 18 18 digne de ce pur qui ont été
supprimés ce gouvernement ment ce
gouvernement est un gouvernement de
menteurs et à la tête du ministère de la
santé en premier lieu vérone j'entendais
tout au tout à l'heure varian oui c'est
exactement le mot c'est inacceptable
c'est intolérable si nous n'avons pas
des réponses alors oui je suis d'accord
il faudra remonter massivement en masse
de partout parce que l'hôpital
c'est à nous c'est la sécurité sociale
et le sun ou contre les fermetures de
lits contre les fermetures de postes et
en aucun cas comme syndicats le passé
pro on nous le mettrons un doigt dans la
gestion de la crise et la destruction du
statut or mes camarades nous avons
raison nous sommes nous la raison et oui
c'est nous qui défendons l'hôpital
public personne autre que nous tous les
hospitaliers médicaux paramédicaux
unités merci mes camarades
[Applaudissements]
c'est
le cas d'alex de chu chino vous avez
tous parlé je te de vous inquiéter
bonjour je vous apporte le salut
fraternel du 37
alors moi je suis secrétaire du coup de
du département 37 et du syndicat fo de
l'hôpital de lachine ont
sinon comme comme partout ailleurs aussi
on supprime des postes et donc je peux
répéter tout ce qui a pu être dit ou
est-ce que je suis complètement d'accord
avec tout ça en fait c'est aussi le mode
comptable c'est le mode comptable qu'on
fait subir aux établissements avec la
t2a qui amène en fait que tous les
ombres à chaque paire d où
l'établissement font le choix de
supprimer des postes ça fait plusieurs
années donc en plus de ce que tout ce
qui a pu être dit c'est je dirais vers
en plus un touraine bachelot ils sont
tous responsables du merdier dans lequel
on est et dans le merdier koné ya aussi
les usagers qui les quittera calories la
prochaine fois il faudra venir avec les
usagers comme a fait mayenne où est-ce
que mayenne et beaucoup de gens de
mayenne c'est très bien bravo à eux
bravo à vous de nous avoir accordé de
vous espérez aujourd'hui merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la fédération cgt de la santé qui veut
s'exprimer
même si oui donc au nom de la fédération
de la santé et de l'action sociale de la
cgt comme vous tous nous tous je veux
dire nous nous l'ensemble on se réunit
encore une fois rassemblés ici pour
dénoncer les fermetures de lits de
l'hôpital public pour dénoncer
évidemment la régression sociale qui
s'installe vraiment drastiquement
masochistes on part évidemment la nomme
employabilité pas la perte de chance qui
s'installe que l'offre de soins par la
diminution des lits et des services et
paradoxalement
évidemment en arriver là cinquième vague
et cette cinquième vague annonce quoi
tous ces gens à l'hôpital trousseau à
l'hôpital necker à la pitié salpêtrière
déjà hier place et il faut profiter des
victimes de bronchiolite c'est purement
et simplement un scandale ce qu'on est
en train de vivre aujourd'hui ces mêmes
criminels alors que c'est vrai on
n'arrête pas de le dire mais cela crée
on a besoin de lui on a dit ne pas
croire évidemment de l'augmentation des
salaires pour connaître nos métiers ces
métiers aussi noble aussi pour
l'humanité que la plus à voir
aujourd'hui dans notre pays il est
scandaleux skoda n'est que ceux des
liens de mort ne nous entendent pas
depuis deux ans et demi sur des bouts
avant que vides les urgences étaient
déjà en grève pour dénoncer le manque de
moyens arrive la période de vide et ils
nous ferment plus de 5000 cette famille
en 2020 en pleine période qu'ovide ou
millions répète c'est scandaleux on ne
cessera de le répéter mais ce qui est le
plus grave c'est qu'on est en train de
mettre la responsabilité juridique tirek
aux soignants qui veut se disant encore
choisir quels patients on va soigner
plutôt qu'un autre salle c'est
scandaleux il faut vraiment même arriver
à ce que nous les personnels ne portons
plainte contre ce gouvernement qui est
en très peu nous abîmer notre protection
sociale et notre système de santé
français est leur ensemble consomment et
c'est vraiment ensemble toutes les
organisations syndicales les
associations les collectifs mais la
chaumière reste au lit parce que face à
ce gouvernement
on verra plus de toute intimité mains
d'un lieu public privé qui elle faut
évidemment des têtes des profits
faramineux russie n'ont pas les moyens
sauf qu'ils se taisent parce que doubler
leur salaire voilà ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est la moto on y met en
concurrence partie soignant soigné
solidarité soignant soigné
solidarité on veut tenir tête passe à
l'hôpital public on veut des vis tes
potes de l'hôpital public
fidèle public au bond et lui
il a mis en
résidence d'autrui collègues ça suffit
toucher et voir été c'est le coup
comment tu sais que rendent la peur au
ventre des soignants du chu hôpital hors
des murs mais pas d'hôpital unis
[Applaudissements]
c'est
réellement kinshasa inscrivez n'est pas
ne pas l'être ensemble c'est le père de
pis ils vont pousser mais alors laissez
pas faire hansson ensemble on veut des
nous tes posts par la pédagogie
[Musique]
à
remercient leurs délégations j'ai bien
ma communiste à plusieurs grandes écoles
[Applaudissements]
l'organisation d'aujourd'hui est partis
de vienne il faut saluer le courage
de cette mobilisation il s'est
généralisé en france parce que la
question de l'hôpital public c'est bien
la question que
l'ensemble de la population
l'hôpital public
c'est le bien de ceux qui n'ont rien
mais j'ai aussi le bien de tout le monde
et c'est grâce à l hôpital public que la
france a fait jeu au niveau de santé
alors tous ensemble nous devons le
défendre et la coordination des comités
de défense des hôpitaux et maternités de
proximité dont fait partie d'ailleurs
11h à mayenne a lancé un appel à
l'ensemble des organisations je vais
dire non spécialistes la chanter pour
défendre le budget public pense que
c'est la sphère de toute la population
car notre accès à une santé de qualité
de proximité
et de moins en moins assuré malgré
l'activation des personnels l'hôpital du
vide se désintègre avec partout des
fermetures de lits de service en
particulier d'urgence et de ce mur mais
aussi en psychiatrie en chirurgie en
médecine au soin de lui
le laisser-faire et les maternités
évidemment il est maternité j'ai sauté
un mot le laisser faire laisser le
problème c'est tous les services de
toute façon le laisser faire et qu elle
dirige le service privé avec des
conséquences dramatiques pour l'accès au
soin de dépassements d'honoraires de
fresnes l'initiative mais aussi de recul
tu la proximité c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire qui sent plus la situation
actuelle des hôpitaux a pour conséquence
d'accroître les souffrances des malades
des personnes en situation de handicap
et de provoquer une surmortalité
le renoncement aux soins s'accroît le
gouvernement ne peut se contenter de
distribuer quelques millions ici et là
pour tenter de calmer les esprits
l'hôpital public est garant de l'accès
au soin de tout et tous et nous
demandons un plan d'urgence pour le
public un shop l'attractivité pour les
personnels par une fois la
reconnaissance salariale par une
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail mais aussi en leur permettant de
travailler conformément lors utile
ce qui suppose de les écouter et de
réformer la gouvernance
il faut changer les systèmes de
fonctionnement et de management basée
sur les critères de performance et de
rentabilité
il n'y a pas de soi sans une amie
l'humanité il faut un vaste plan de
formation de recrutement et la
titularisation des contractuels
la réouverture de tous les leviers
service fermées et des ouvertures autant
que de besoin l'établissement d'une
vraie démocratie sanitaire unissant
personnels et usagers citoyens les
moyens financiers suffisants avant
d'être donnée par une modification du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale alors cette année il a
été repris par plus de 80 organisations
et je développe mais vous les citer sont
sur le site de la coordination bien
quand même attaque ya la ligue des
droits de l'homme il ya et la fsu il ya
un certain nombre de syndicats il ya un
certain nombre de partis politiques je
ne vais pas vous faire cette liste ne
peut pas être compliqué mais
véritablement cette exigence d'un plan
d'urgence pour l'hôpital et reprise par
de très nombreuses organisations qui
représentent la population est
pratiquement les soignants affreux c'est
bien les usagers actuellement qui sont
balade malades de ne pas pouvoir accéder
à l'hôpital et son miel et les usagers
ils apportent aussi leur soutien à tous
les personnels car ils sont conscients
de ce que vous faites mais ils savent
aussi qu'il faut se battre pour avoir un
hôpital public de qualité
merci beaucoup donc comme anormales
revient de délégation de la délégation
revient donc je vais
bonjour je suis c'est vrai c'est l'art
de le secrétaire général du syndicat
force ouvrière de l'hôpital
trois fans
bon le le colin et le copain de hoda 53
faudra le fera le compte rendu notre
audience mais je vous rassure et on
n'attendait pas grand chose on n'est pas
déçu
je regarde le mot de l'hôpital de
bagnols lorsque le 9 octobre alors que
nous étions plus de 4000 manifestants à
mayenne pour nourrir non au dépeçage de
l'hôpital et qu'à cette occasion nous
avons proposé de monter à paris le 4
décembre pour obtenir des garanties de
pérennité de l'hôpital nous ne pensions
pas que notre initiative allait faire
boule de neige et que de très très
nombreuses invitations nous suivraient
en mayenne nous sommes modestes nous
avons bien compris que ce qu'ils ont se
sont saisis de notre initiative ne l'ont
pas fait parce qu'ils sont éperdument
amoureux de notre beau département mais
bien parce qu'il sait ce qui se passe en
mayenne n'est qu'un triste exemple parmi
tant d'autres on ne refait pas à celle
département ne connais n'a pas connu ne
connaîtra pas une restructuration une
fermeture de services d'olli ou
d'hôpital si nous ne serons pas leur
politique néfaste
apparemment ils veulent pas un lieu pas
la stopper non plus
après l'entretien à mayenne le projet de
la rs consiste simplement à vider de son
territoire une grande partie de ces lits
au détriment de la santé de 100000
habitants déjà largement impactés quand
la désertification médicale et c'est
l'axé la confirme la politique de
destruction du gouvernement en métier en
matière de santé publique
car il s'agissait pour le gouvernement
d'aller au bout de la logique de la loi
ma santé 2022 d'aller au bout de la
logique des groupes hospitaliers
territoire et de continuer de fermer des
lits et supprimer des postes en
recentrant l'activité sur les hôpitaux
dits support en mayenne depuis huit mois
et même avant les salariés avec force
ouvrière la population avec
l'association da 53 et les élus nous
nous battons pour le maintien de notre
hôpital nous sommes aujourd'hui plus de
500 manifestants des pays de la loire
pour défendre l'hôpital public
et je remercie au passage du défaut 75
et du riz pour leur aide logistique
même pendant la pandémie rien ne les
arrête le gouvernement a supprimé sa
5758 en 2020 en mayenne comme partout
ailleurs nous refusons le faire partie
des statistiques de 2021 et des années
suivantes les mobilisations en mayenne
ont bûché castex de nommer un médiateur
pour apaiser la situation
sur tous les territoires français la
seule médiation possible c'est le
maintien des hôpitaux la réouverture des
lits et des services l'embauché massive
du personnel hospitalier la population
les soignants le disent et le répètent
quand c'est non c'est non ils ne veulent
pas de la fermeture de leurs hôpitaux et
nous sommes déterminés
car au projet des ars se rajouter
fermetures de lits par milliers par
manque d'effectif de soignants il ne
s'agit pas seulement d'un problème
conjoncturel comme on veut nous le faire
croire mais ce sont bien les
conséquences des politiques de santé que
nous dénonçons depuis des années
des centaines de service sont fermées
les plans sont déclenchées par tous tous
les jours dans les pays la loire une
demi douzaine de services d'urgence et
de ce mur sont au mieux en procédure
dégradé fermé un jour sur deux voire
plus tous les hôpitaux sont adaptés même
les chu les conséquences sur la santé
des citoyens sont dramatiques on le
commence à le lire dans tous les
journaux
nous sommes des centaines de milliers à
ne plus avoir accès à la santé les
agents hospitaliers fui hôpital public à
cause des conditions de travail et ce
malgré les augmentations de rémunération
avec le ségur arraché par les
mobilisations avant et pendant la crise
et nous continuerons à nous battre pour
l'amélioration et l'extension des
mesures pour tous les changements
continuels des plannings les changements
d'horaires les rappels incessants sur
les rebonds les précarités finissent par
a cure et où les hospitaliers seul
embauches massives de personnel
hospitalier forme et améliorera les
conditions d'exercice
les semaines passent et la situation des
hôpitaux ce temps le nombre nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que la seule
réponse du gouvernement soient des plans
cosmétiques et marchetti il ya urgence
les promesses la main sur le coeur de la
fin du dogme d'un fermeture des lits ont
vite été oubliée et le top de la
politique d'austérité d'équilibré
comptable a vite repris sa place
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que ce
gouvernement continue la transformation
de l'égal accès aux soins en écu talent
en équitable accès aux soins qui se
termine terminera par plus du tout
d'accès
de nombreux endroits
le combat contre l'effondrement
hospitalier s'organise et les réactions
sont importantes mais nous ne pourrons
pas nous battre chacun de notre côté
avec plus ou moins de soutien de succès
il est de notre devoir de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour sauver l'hôpital public non
syndicats fortement mobilisée avec leur
union départementale force ouvrière
considère que le combat pour la défense
de l'hôpital public mais pas que la
ferme et hospitaliers mais de toute la
population
nous considérons que l'initiative du 4
décembre doit être un tremplin pour la
reconquête de l'hôpital public et cela
dans l'unité la plus large possible
merci
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
camarades langis tu allais par l
excès rapidement camarades à la mayenne
a raison cette affaire la défense de
l'hôpital public sénat faire de tous ces
l'interprofessionnelle la population
tout le monde doit s'y mettre oscar
angers et je vous apporte ce livre est
humaine des camarades chez hq d'angers
angers aussi aux gens s'ils détruisent
ils détruisent hôpital public depuis
2018 ce sont 135 lits d'hospitalisation
complète qu'ils ont supprimée
j'indique au passage que les médecins
des urgences les médecins des urgences
du us a eu le service d'accueil des
urgences adultes est entré en grève le
30 novembre dernier comme le 30 novembre
dernier nous étions avec les
ambulanciers hospitalier ici même on
part d'une part du ministère pour
réclamer la revalorisation de leur
statut la reconnaissance en catégorie b
pour les ambulanciers mais toute cette
affaire c'est la sphère de tous
aujourd'hui c'est tout le milieu
hospitalier qui doit se lever
aujourd'hui le ministre hubert orange
même le comprendre dans la négation qui
vient d'être reçue ils n'ont pas décidé
de changer taille haute à leur politique
de destruction ils ont décidé de
continuer à se liquéfier le budget des
hôpitaux et ça c'est intolérable qu'il
commence à réintégrer tous les
personnels suspendu faute à un juge
aucun collègue franck est de trop côté
supprimé un service de cardio à cause
d'un médecin suspendu qui a dû fermer 14
10 de cardiologie est ce que c'est
normal aujourd'hui c'est extra ils sont
partout en france y'a pas un hôpital en
guadeloupe en martinique
tous ont atteint là dessus et c'est
intolérable donc aujourd'hui il faut
dire stop à cette destruction et si
c'est pas vers heures qui veut répondre
ce sera ma cran et ce sera un elysée
qu'il faudra s'arrêter tout ça c'était
limité à telle heure
look à l'élu pour les pesc
l'intérieur après la pointure des sacs
en finale
pour écouter les là messieurs chers
camarades chers amis lorsque le 9
octobre ont annoncé à mayenne enfin
manifestation qui avait réuni plus de
3000 personnes 3500 personnes quand la
défense de l'hôpital public de mayenne
lorsqu'on a annoncé que le 4 décembre on
monterait à part à paris mais on n'osait
pas imaginer que nous serions si
nombreux et qu'autant de gens de partout
nous rejoindrait mais à la limite ça
nous étonne tant parce que finalement ce
qui se passe à marianne ce qui se passe
à laval ce n'est que l'illustration à
échelle réduite de ce qui se passe
partout partout tous les témoignages que
l'onda fonds éteint dans un hôpital
public est en train de se déliter des
urgences qui ferment des services qui
ferment des leaders qui n'existe prix et
ce qui fait que ça met la population en
danger nous avons sur la mayenne les
services d'urgences de l'hôpital de
laval qui ont été fermés plusieurs
foires plusieurs jours ce qui a pour
conséquence que sollicité le soudan j'ai
avec les régulatrice qui doit réguler le
l'intervention des secours sur un
territoire qu'elle ne connaît pas c'est
une véritable catastrophe la population
est en danger et c'est sacré ministère
ne veut pas entendre
nous pensons qu'il faut véritablement
que la population entière et pas
seulement les soignants sortent dans la
rue les soignants sont épuisés sont
cassées ont été complètement
assommé par la critique au vide ils ont
cru pendant quelques temps que la
nomination à laquelle il avait à faire
face pendant les périodes pré- chaude à
l'hôpital allait enfin raté le ministère
à la raison et faire en sorte que ce ne
soit plus jamais après comme c'était
avant en fait ce n'est pas comme c'était
avant c'est pire
[Musique]
ce n'est absolument pas supportable
alors bien sûr on est content que vous
soyez là tous tous les tout tous les
gens qui ne sont pas de la baguette qui
soit qui ait répondu à notre appel mais
on se doute bien malgré que la sympathie
que vous nous portez on n'en doute pas
que ce n'est pas seulement pour nos
beaux yeux c'est parce que la situation
est la même partout on peut re a égrené
un tas de peter la liste d'hôpitaux qui
sont en difficulté aujourd'hui on
pourrait parler
au
printemps on pourrait parler de voiron
du chu nantes saint malo tellement
colmar chu de saint-etienne qui restent
en lice et un chapitre des tirs au but
triais chu de strasbourg le bailleur
pour et cetera et cetera et cetera larry
tanit la liste ça pourrait me tenir
jusqu'à ce soir partout l'hôpital public
est en danger partout l'hôpital public
et dans le menace d'un effondrement
complet il y à tous sens il y a deux ans
oda 53 et fait le choix de faire monter
entre guillemets comme on dit en
province un quart de 50 l'usagé pour
rejoindre la manifestation du 14
novembre
2019 nous avions été heureusement
surpris de voir la mobilisation et
mettez des soignants en revanche vous
avez été déçu de voir le petit singe et
le peu de citoyens qu'il y avait dans la
rue il tombait sur rien absolument que
la population se lève cette situation
n'est plus tolérable la population est
en danger les soigner son temps les
soignants sont en danger il faut
absolument que partout il se lève et des
îles se créent des comités des
associations que la population s'élève
dans quelques mois il sera peut-être
trop tard tout qu'on défend les copies
des mythes que vous ça c'est des
formations professionnelles commis par
défaut mais fini il est hors de
question d'accepter cette situation nous
sommes sans danger nous allons nous
lever pour défendre les communes et
merci à nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mike
mike la parole
est ce ça aurait tout sa parole mais il
ya un petit temps donc s'il vous plaît
merci
oui bonjour à tous je me trouve ici
c'est pas la première fois tout l'été je
suis venue manifester
je suis une soignante suspendu oui sans
moyens de subsister depuis le 15
septembre
pas d'arrêt maladie j'ai enchaîné
directement mes dernières nuits de
travail à avec une suspension dans les
heures qui ont suivi mon mettais mes
dernières heures travaillées ce que je
voulais dire c'est que beaucoup de
collègues se sont fait vacciner sa scène
c'est un choix
et pas seulement parce que beaucoup sous
la contrainte moi j'ai voulu exercer mon
principe de précaution le consentement
libre et éclairé voilà de choisir face à
un vaccin voilà qui ne me convient pas
on nous ment beaucoup depuis le début
sur les chiffres oui les chiffres
d'hospitalisation en faite le on se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans un vrai diktat
sanitaire alors que j'ai appelé ça le
diktat sanitaires effectivement nous
avons travaillé au tout l'été sans
interruption en 12 heures en enchaînant
parfois des retours sur des repos des
vacances annulé
voilà nous nous sommes effectivement
épuisé
et en colère oui oui monsieur verrons
nous sommes en colère quel est ce
gouvernement qui en toute impunité
enlève le droit du sud restée aux
soignants aux citoyens sans droit aux
aides sociales
quel crime avons nous commis à part
s'occuper des gens des malades à quel
crime avons nous commis
nous avons travaillé sans compter et
pendant ce temps là on supprime encore
des lits ont regroupé des services oui
pendant la crise ou une ferme et
enfermer des services on composait de
deux services un seul
[Musique]
c'est une situation c'est une situation
intolérable pour moi on nous a d'une
violence inouïe on nous a on use as a
violenté méprisés c'est c'est une
véritable humiliation
le gouvernement je suis très émue
effectivement mais ma situation a fait
en sorte que je peux l'être ce
gouvernement pour moi aujourd'hui bah il
est qu'il est légitime à coude et à
gouverner notre pays les noyer dans les
affaires de corruption de conflit
d'intérêts pour moi il a plus lieu de
gouverner la france nous sommes que nous
sommes plus dans un état de droit pour
tous
nos gouvernants sont déconnectés du
corps social ils sont devenus toxiques
toxique pour la population il faut que
les gens se réveillent et que la
population que les mouvements citoyens
rejoignent tous les mouvements
politiques apolitique il faut une vraie
convergence pour que la lui la lutte
arrive enfin arrêter de se morceler
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on veut vraiment
minimes hommes je pense bien tenir en
forme de coeur
je ne me prends comme un charme et
collègues en activité
moi j'interviens en fait pour demander
un hôpital parce que on paie james c'est
à dire au bout de du département de
l'indre la frontière suisse nous sommes
130 mille habitants et nous n'avons pas
d'hôpital nous n'avons jamais eu un
hôpital et nous devrons
nous dépendons d'un contrat
territorial de santé scandaleuse qui
nous fait dépendre des hôpitaux de
haute-savoie d'annecy est saint julien
en genevois et nous devons franchir deux
fois deux voies la frontière suisse pour
aller au zoo bitton tant qu'homme et et
s'il ya des embouteillages nous devons
attendre ça peut prendre trois quarts
d'heure ça peut prendre une heure et
demie aux deux heures pour accepter à
l'hôpital voir plus dans connu des
sorties nous dénonçons ce contrat
territorial est scandaleux que qui est
imposé par la rs éducation par le
ministère de la santé et et nounous
secours pensant qu effectivement un ici
nous pourrons pas arriver chacun pour
soi et que nous devons tous nous unir et
nous nous avons le soutien la désunion
le garn cgt force ouvrière et un soupçon
t800 et les départements de l'ain et
nous pensons que tous ici nous devons
vraiment nous unir parce qu'il faut
créer un rapport de force seul le
rapport de force
permettra de être contraint de
satisfaire nos revendications parce que
comme le disait un camarade avant qu'ils
ont leur feuille de route tracée est
leur feuille de route c'est la
destruction complète l'attenté des
hôpitaux publics dans ce pays y voilà
franck
oui bonjour mes camarades moi j'attends
bien entendu l'hymne national de la
santé privée force ouvrière il ya
quelques quelques jours avec nos
camarades de la santé privée de la cgt
on a décidé de répondre intense des
cajas devienne pas ce que conçoit du
privé comtois du public quand on est
salarié de la santé avait maltraité la
nef temporairement
comme il est donc peu trop du privé se
sont garés avec quoi qu'il en coûte ils
en ont mis plein les poches aujourd'hui
les actionnaires reçoivent est évidente
alors que les salariés quittent le
métier de plus en plus on te fous de
tout celle réponse gens différents nous
répond tout jeune c'est la quête des
conventions collectives
aujourd'hui ils veulent découverte
unique ce n'est pas pour rien des
camarades c'est pour avoir une cette
convention dans l'attenté je plus bas
niveau possible pour un jour y intégrer
votre statut donc ne soyons pas d'où tu
es fou dans les conventions collectives
plus des nerfs statut et c'est tout ça
c'est que nous y arriverons donc c'est
pour ça que privés publient tous un
verbe
stephen kavanagh j'ai fait car si
j'étais
oui bonjour à toutes et tous en sont ou
même se tient notre manifestation c'est
la deuxième manifestation contre le
chômage et la précarité qui est
organisée par les chômeurs cgt des
associations ac apeis mncp
et notamment bond a été pour pour venir
avant tout
porter votre notre soutien et notre
solidarité à votre mobilisation est
et donc voilà on est arrivé on puisse
aller quelque part intéressait pas avant
tout parce que
notre combat pour le service public et
en l'occurrence pour le service public
et de la santé et de l'action sociale
c'est quelque chose qui est essentiel qu
auront bien entendu et c'est sont celles
aussi pour les usagers et usagers de
rousseau et on sait bien que ce qu'ils
ont le coeur d'êta risée dans leur vie
dans leur travail sont encore plus
dépendantes de ce service public de son
ex et billy l'accessibilité de sa
possibilité comme n'existe plus on n'a
plus rien parce qu'on n'a pas l'argent
pour aller gagner en confort prenons
donc votre combat contre la suppression
des services pourtant la suppression de
vie pour remettre des services à ouvrir
la marque là où il y en a deux au bien
ça ce combat là que vous connaissez
d'autres combats aussi et en le mènent
ensemble ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point que je l'évoquais
rapidement c'est que où notre première
exigence est la première exigence dans
notre manifestation là c'est le droit le
droit au travail le droit au travail et
l'accès à l'emploi est resté à l emprunt
stable en est à un emploi correct et et
ça c'est aussi le combat contre la
précarité est sûre c'est sur ces thèmes
là je pense aussi qu'on se retrouve
véritablement sur sur votre bataille
aaron il faut quand même savoir qu'il ya
plus de sept millions
deux brides de plus travailleur son
esprit à apalon potes
et donc
certains disent qu'il suffit de
travailler la rue pour courir non quoi
je ne pense pas que 6,7 millions de
travailler en traversant la rue ils vont
tous
vos lentilles et choisissent des rues
eux de les ramener
de plus de plus et ça me semble
important quand même on peut pas poser
cette question de la quantité de
l'emploi sans poser la question de la
qualité c'est pour ça que je parle et la
précarité c'est à dire que
que vos envies la dégradation des
conditions de travail mais ça vous le
vivez en entendant qu'au secteur des
salaires des salaires misérables
et aurait
donc des garanties aux dégradés tout
cela ça fait que
départ
parfois partant préférable au chômage et
en même temps il faut arrêter qu'on dise
que n'importe quel emploi et mieux que
de pâles emploi du temps parce que ce
qui nous qui sort en tête les accepterai
jamais ces enfants là il n'est travers
les habitants ont un temps dans ces
conditions là il faut arrêter de dire ça
oui bien sûr notre première
revendication c'est un bon corner ça non
un emploi avec des droits avec des
garanties et avec un salaire qui
réactive à lyon
donc je disais l'emploi est au coeur de
notre mobilisation et et en même temps
on passe à la question de
l'indemnisation pour ceux qui en sont
privés parce que c'est pas une question
qui est un qui
parallèle elle va en même temps ceux qui
sont privés d'emploi qui sont
involontairement privé d'emploi par le
fait que des politiques sociales et de
la politique du patronat aujourd'hui
ceux qui sont privés d'emploi indemnisés
et doit avoir un revenu dans seulement
10 ans et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
porte lentement et avec aujourd'hui en
passant une réforme qui se met en place
qui s'est mis en place l'un d'eux le 1er
décembre total en une oraison décrété
unilatéralement outre mis en place par
par le gouvernement ne réponde banque de
l'assurance chômage qui est concrètement
aussi qu'ils réforment vraiment à ça
s'il dit concrètement beaucoup de 2
millions de
travailleur qui les emploient veut dire
que soit ils sont privés d'eau potable
anisation parce que
par le fait qu'ils font est pas assez
cotisé soit qu'ils voient leur
organisation wc et au moyen de 20 2%
sachant que en moyenne les
indemnisations à pôle emploi sont
appelés tous sont en moyenne de 911
euros donc 22 pour cent de moyens il
faut imaginer qu'alain de ce que ça veut
dire concrètement pour la vie des gens
donc alors je suis né vite et je vous
renvoie notamment vers notre site
internet de qualité sonore de la cécité
son retour en coupe
ou là dessus mais qu'on finir continuant
juste sur deux là se moque de cette
réforme est de la situation
s'améliore
on peut dire
et pour cause
d
non
je pense comme ça
[Musique]
aïcha la fille
moi je suis
moi c'est du passé
quand
le monde à ses pieds
justement pas sans toi
[Musique]
mettez la au rouleau
ajouté
nous allons chercher
l'oratoire elle
mais
en juillet on vous ne comprenez pas
pourquoi les fidèles étaient deux
offices locaux en en souffrance à leurs
fins puis les électeurs de plus
plusieurs en aidant
et que celui qui menace toutes les
formes de kick-ass nos établissements il
a été
en tournée
les formes notamment dans la région de
l'eau traitée de nombreux mystères
[Musique]
probable qui a tassé
et les plannings de tous les collègues
du forail à l'hôpital et qui aujourd'hui
ne savent plus où ils en sont partis aux
élections continuellement la télé alors
sur leur temps de repos pour venir
travailler calmement énormément j'étais
petit en aura dans les hôpitaux
aujourd'hui
montreux support du h d'état denis fermé
sur les tables ce sens qu antoine ya 70
lits fermés ce qui veut dire aujourd'hui
en europe et j'ai de devenir patients
qu'on pourra pas les intérêts que les
obligés de reculer leurs interventions
et leurs consultations parce qu'on
manque d'effectifs au manque de médecins
on manque de soignants et quand je gage
de soignants souffert tous les
infirmiers et une ex wagne en manque de
brancardier on a un manque de
techniciens de laboratoire pour moi
on manque d'assistantes sociales et
ongles anquetil kéfi ciel le manque de
tirer
l'hôpital en gros représente tous les
salariés il faut pas se focaliser que
sur les infirmières
à l'hôpital au revoir à croiser en
première
période
de tous les fondamentaux pouvoir
travailler correctement dans
la carrière avec de meilleures
conditions
j'ai envie tu fais rien pour les
soignants on l'a demandé
koné qui sont suspendus et on veut
qu'ils soient réintégrés il refuse de
les réintégrer alors qu'on est
pourtant on est en plein dans la 5ème
pas il les agressait nous implique avec
le co vie de tous les geeks par doni
retour à force de nous donner des marges
moi je me souviens que dans mon
établissement en 2020 on a déposé à la
régie parce qu'on le voit je lui donnais
des moeurs que d'après les services moi
même j'ai été impliqué en endocrinologie
parce que le pneu
ce qu'on ne fait pas de masque et
londres- de mes collègues sont tombés
dans la première vague et aujourd'hui on
en a encore qui souffrent de cette
maladie dont la veille chez monsieur
vers en vaudra un jour répondent de ce
crime pour soi jeu tous les soignants
dans le département
on
mais sont venus du grand est a remis
dans les rues proches pour exiger à
planter l'habitacle est pris comme nous
n'avons marqué sur la marquise quand tu
es jolie copie notre hôpital et souffre
de fermeture du service de cardiologie
du service ne manquent -sur le givre la
fermeture des vannes et de récits de la
primature nationale
capitale souffre d'une ombre praticiens
hospitaliers
comme dans les bons jours moines ont
ramené la langue de porc à benito et la
mort j'ai pu ajouter de latence
ces mamans dans l'esprit des gens avec
les démissions et la fuite et comme les
young boys yb et la question mon
admiration le manque d'activité du
public vient s'ajouter aux problèmes
démographiques
comme et encore je rencontre ce mardi
lycée dégâts
d'autant qu'en résistance de la
population avec saisie du syndicat les
professionnels des sorties
empêcher la fermeture de la maternité et
à préserver notre hôpital de territoire
avec la ville de xining
au coeur de cette résistance entre
associations réjouir banner la formation
de coopération répondent volontiers pour
lesquels la santé n'est pas une
marchandise
comme les autres services
le service public autres tapié carrière
comprendre
samedi dernier 27 novembre comme c'est
du hockey 250 personnes la kabylie
de l'avis de remiremont il faut faire de
neige moi aussi j'ai le match avait des
gens en couches depuis pour concert 24
heures sur 24 et ce en mode
car c'est trop souvent apprécié
donc
[Musique]
l'autre association et pratique on
subira du corps se sont allés en justice
car la dimension judiciaire et aussi
dimension en bas du dos production au
japon
[Musique]
un
jeune majeur notamment annoncé mireille
sous la montagne dimanche et le nom
repos pour nom la création rapide d'un
service du quartier il a 48 ans
coronarographie ça me revient
mourad pour moi quand obligé dans la
majorité noire civile
est bien loin du show pour se faire
soigner dans ce département qualité
cardiovasculaires et si l'infection
devant qualité sera plus de table et
qu'on sent tellement que l'unocam isoc
france si nous voulions bien que le
problème est global menu photos de lézat
plan d'urgence asile
gérard tschopp d'attractivité à la fois
pour les professionnels
mais c'est aussi pour les sikhs en a eu
l'âge et qu'une fois c'est le sens de la
présence de toutes les délégations et
s'y présentent c'est le sens de la
prison
des gens venus à la paix
sur les étals des comités de défense des
hôpitaux et maternités de proximité
donc ça tous les gens et des
rassemblements dans toute la france
corot 7 paris à guingamp façon par agent
sarlam 2 au centre etc merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
la source
[Musique]
non
il
aussi m
[Musique]
non
sage
[Musique]
il vas-y
et
je n'ai pas
[Musique]
collé comme ceux qui passaient
la raison
merci portable
à trois conditions
mais
m
qui en trois ans
des sorties
on souhaite pouvoir
quelques impressions des façons pour la
boîte
assure le chercheur
comment japon
ces parts
le rapport
[Musique]
/
cet accord
[Musique]
voilà
fort
autant vous dire
ok mais ce qui est
service
voilà
rendu là
ou pas
on du genre drame nous manquera pour les
bayonnais les titres
comment les arènes dans ses victoires
puisque comme il l'a dit ça fait encore
jour d'avant départ
les yeux ornée de recul pendant trois
quarts d'heure discussions franches et
les corps d'homme fort courant désirs et
ea sola 10 et ont concédé 2
od rend bien lesdites et danton
préparée en avant d'entretenir
de l'occident que l'auditoire des
collectes pour les adhésions et gagner
absolument
engagement alors le seul beau s'octroie
positif parce qu'il faut bien
quelque chose de positif c'est que tout
est entre les mains d'un clan du rapport
que va faire du bien à la fin du mois de
décembre alors c'est vrai que les
premières les produits et le médiateur
des moteurs quelques données par jean
castex des témoignages c'est vrai que
les premiers
contacts pro numérique et sociale aiguë
qui soit
ans et 70 tragique monaco des
possibilités de rang soir
comme j'ai dit
en conséquence
ça fait six mois qu'on nous balade
certes depuis six mois on a réussi pas
de mobilisation a planté reste à reculer
battant au c'est aussi le missile a qu'à
chaque fois qu'il rendait le projet qui
m'attire c'est pour mille à en sortir
quelques mois près d'hambourg n'est
absolument pas du procès et aussi moche
des traces encore une fois les arguments
de co2 capté dans son corps et le temps
c'est une contrainte au fonds
d'assurance la colonisation et les
pulsions de limites et alcool tommasone
on mange des auditeurs sont abandonnés
continuent leur marche en avant des bas
pour que les urgences en particulier
auxonne correctement condamnant patients
qui arrivent dans les centrales et
conditionne tout ce qui fonctionne en
parle avec intéressement quatre
attentats notamment tanger d'état on n'a
pas plus que la bôme finalement d'un
gris au poteau tous cas ce que dit grand
chose maintenant que va continuer avec
à parler avec le joker et on espère que
en fin d'automne ont trois blancs si ce
n'est de coquilles heureux tout et
lumière merci en tout cas à tous d'avoir
été la foulée mais gêné on va rejoindre
la place beauvau pour reprendre les
quarts d'heure assez plus tard
c'est par là
la direction a
mis ces noms
quand j'ai dit
tout à l'heure je consommais les pythons
personnes tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est ce qui fait l'histoire du comité
pour donnerait au lait nous parlons pas
giannina on en doute
sinon c'est pour sa mission
la vérité de la suivante
15 jours en raison de 1000 euros là
c'est qu'il
oublie le reste à charge okani quand
apparu clair
m
je me suis tombé
voilà
des gens qui me plaît
qui paiera quand la population dans son
camp
parce que
je suis pas sûr
on chante ce type on y est c'est fait
que paris
parmi les
bien sûr oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci les faits c'est quand même à
quelques uns quant aux joueurs de la
sarthe parce que nous sommes là
aujourd'hui le silence ou pire à la
mayenne nous sommes complets
c'est peu comparé la manière mais ça
existe c'est bien nous sommes une
délégation de ces hôpitaux
bien sûr
[Musique]
soit parti
dans la salle il y a cinq hôpitaux
publics
s'était plaint de son temps dit on à
loudenvielle encore qu'on a compris que
sur sur scène btu léger qui la croient
qu'ils dressent garder
dans son siège auto france dont je suis
président de 2,8 à 2,5 depuis 27 ans
bientôt gratuit apprécié depuis ce
temps-là à maintenir le service
urgence à maintenir un certain nombre de
services dont des chirurgiens que la
part pour un dizaine d'années
aujourd'hui c'est de plus en plus
difficile on nous a fermé le week-end
dernier les urgences des pallières il
est né sur le dos pour te pose en
permanence rien
et personne en détresse alors avec lui
aujourd'hui il y à l'hôpital
représentation de vol sur loire chapleau
dont le président est ici à côté droit
et puis on fait 10 181 cas des ions à
son association défense me l'a fait tant
de loi
191 adhésion de loi c lire la volonté de
la population de préserver son hôpital
public il y avait un camp de gens du
bail elle y est même en défense grâce
aux dons pour s'appeler service en force
vers lui et des petits hôpitaux il a
aussi
des élus c'est important jeu
aujourd'hui je crois que vous considérez
cette
maria ce qu'aucun
droit et qu'ils aient tous
fixation et de droit du lait je crois
pour toute cette journée du 4 2 en est
une preuve
il va falloir produire travailler
ensemble à travailler que les élus les
scènes personnel la populace
association parcours ce kit les il le
faut il faut que les gens dans la
population ce tome de moyenne
rend leur service public de proximité
des hôpitaux continuité on a de quoi
payer lorsque vous téléphonez au mit les
écoles proximité
nanterre - et des pauvres ce sont des
shérifs comique toi activités cela
relève d'une barrière du maillage but
n'est qu'à deux territoires il ferait
tout ça alors il faudra sans doute corp
vient d'ici
merci
[Musique]
merci à tous les présents chaque
participation compte
le combat que vous commencez votre
sixième au camarade président
je réponds jaune il a jusqu'au bout on
ne laissera pas
d'accord
que cette façon des soignants alors moi
je suis du fifre 56 mans clients les
fonds qui représentent l'hôpital de
lorient devals de se dorer le vélille ce
qu'il voit c'est une catastrophe dans
tous les services on demande un maximum
aux soignants augmentation de 8 heures à
12 heures ouah quel service à suivre
parce que les effectifs manque déjà tous
les cas auparavant et ce encore pire
même les cadres sont en berne de se
cacher dans les services donc le combat
poids et au coach adjoint
aussi à votre peau dans restructure pour
défendre à votre cause la course est
soignée en quarts et venant se voit il
son mas d'avall issus quand tu good
également car dans la prostitution
illégale les avocats des trois prévenus
me lâcher
i la défense à soignants en une grande
roue est et de la france il ya vingt
sept 27 articles qui sont en désaccord
avec la loi sont illégales aux 6-10 ans
livre une fois français gilles voire
européen et du droit international
lorsqu'on voulait moins dire ce qu'ils
vont se battre dans seulement à des
chiffres communiqués ce temps tous
ensemble et on continuera le combat
juridique ne lâchez pas gardé la foi
alors contacté le collectif de la région
a déjà joué à pour le maillage policier
tire et à votre goût dans votre région
pour réponse de paris espère isoler
seulement il n'est plus de mise
tous solidaires entre eux travailler
ensemble à réparer
des dégâts
pendant millions pour la créer le
collectif en soignant de lorient et de
maggy gagner
donc c'est important parce que nous
avons trouvé des meilleurs de l'auteur
la région des fonds de droit public de
tribunal le tribunal
elle a banni des demandes
d'aidés soignants suspendu de lorient et
de vannes ce n'est qu'un début et ce qui
se passe dans l'ambiance aussi grave
comme dans toutes les régions tout le
monde est concerné à ce qui se passe un
peu on assiste à la fermeture de
l'hôpital de contenu pour ceux qui
connaissent ainsi 1 500 kilomètres de
vannes et sur la catch-up italie ainsi
qu'aux logique où c'est une hécatombe au
niveau des conditions de travail déjà
les conditions étaient très difficiles
j'ai eu la responsable syndicale hier au
téléphone j'étais à moitié en pleurs
elle existe une caennaise comme ce qui
se passe cette semaine était plein pour
ce temps de fermeture des services dans
le temps le dira l'hôpital de lever
scène à s'intégrer à l'équipe de prades
c'est une catastrophe voilà dont je vais
vous dire de lâcheté rien le combat ne
fait que commencer
on y connait bible d'accord à bien des
labours et pourquoi tu mets comme moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
moi je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
oh
les
[Musique]
avec fanny
rose
[Musique]
mais